[Music]
days gone seas released this year and
whilst many are exhibiting it as a
revolutionary open-world zombie game
there currently exists a heavily
underrated one that I think many fans of
the genre overlook that game is dying
light celebrating its third year
anniversary I was surprised at how
unrepresented this release is often
missing the coverage and placement in
top 10 lists that so rightly deserves
dying light should be regarded more
highly than it is on the surface it
seems like a mix between Mirror's Edge
and Dead Island
however thematically and aesthetically
there is a lot more going on beneath its
horrifying surface beyond the fact that
the title heavily implies the creeping
in of darkness and need for rest and
sleep as the night takes over there are
also several signifiers that symbolize
dying lights correlation with a
nightmare dropped off into the fictional
middle-eastern city of Harran players
are instantly hit with a key motif of
dying light the feeling of falling into
a deep deep sleep that one is unable to
escape from catapulting into a twisted
vision of a paradise city one would be a
miss for not noticing the similarities
between the town and what most would
describe as a dream vacation the Sun is
glaring the beaches are beautiful and
the surroundings seem like the perfect
mix between a metropolis in a sunbathing
City this is heaven on earth or so it
would seem should things not go awry our
hero is instantly shocked out of his
dreamlike state upon the realisation
that the entire cityscape is in
festered with the undead much like a
dream throughout the entire game the
hero is given little guidance
one must stumble across guns and figure
out how to use them on their own
often I wandered into dangerous areas
misguided and afraid and there is a
sense of fear to the exploration that
one must injure in order to progress
even after 50 hours of playing I'm still
learning new tricks such as opening car
trunks lock-picking and police vans and
scavenging what I can from this living
and breathing digital nightmare the
story does very little hand-holding and
few will make it this is perfect as it
allows the game to have that extra level
of tension there is no magic guide or
trick tour that you can use to get out
of situations if you are to survive you
must become a survivor the game further
cements itself is the perfect
personification of a nightmare when the
player decides to venture into the night
running blindly with nothing but a
flashlight to guide them the inability
to see more than what is visible in the
cone of the torch provided gives the
world a claustrophobic feeling players
are trapped cut off from what is going
on around them often traveling blindly
through the environment and able to see
what is around the next corner this is
similar to how the human brain operates
during sleep enemies are stronger faster
and infinitely more dangerous gamers
must hurry back to their bed to escape
the nightmare and it perfectly
encapsulates the ideology that this is a
dream gone wrong a different kind of
sleep is the only refuge players ought
to survive if one decides to venture
into the night you will instantly be hit
by the changity dynamics this is your
deepest and darkest fears and the only
defense is to run even though you know
that your legs are barely enough to
carry you and your strength is not
enough to fight back players must go
into an almost docile state in order to
make
this too captures the feeling of sleep
paralysis as one must simply fall back
into one surroundings and accept
whatever fate the demons in the dark
decide for them with regular updates and
continuing support from developers plus
an amazing bass game dying light is
definitely a journey worth taking if
like me you waited nearly three years
before picking it up then you are
definitely in for a breathtaking
surprise there is a lot going on here
and it is one of my favorite horror
games of all time you won't want to miss
this thanks for checking out my analysis
of dying light the following do you
agree with my conclusion that it is
based heavily around the inner workings
of a dream comment below and let me know
and make sure you subscribe to my
youtube channel as I post movie comic
and game related analyzation 's every
week thanks for watching take care peace
[Music]